an der belastungsgrenze
die korona zahlen bleiben hoch und viele
kliniken kämpfen mit enormen
herausforderungen schweizer
flickenteppich nach heftiger kritik
beschließen unsere nachbarn schärfere
regeln vieles bleibt aber den kantonen
überlassen
angst vor dem no deal drexhage die zeit
für verhandlungen läuft ab und britische
unternehmen sehen in eine ungewisse
zukunft
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten an diesem samstag
norbert könig ist auch hier mit dem
sport guten abend deutschland wartet auf
den impfstoff von beyond eck und pfizer
am montag will die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema ihre beurteilung
abgeben dann wird er zugelassen
mit dem impfen los gehen soll es am 27
dezember ein anlass zur hoffnung
angesichts der derzeitigen lage
denn das robert koch institut meldet nun
31.300 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 2862 mehr als vor einer
woche
700 zwei menschen starben in verbindung
mit dem virus bundesweit am stärksten
betroffen ist weiterhin sachsen viele
krankenhäuser arbeiten am limit
auch im benachbarten thüringen ist die
lage ernst aus einer klinik in saalfeld
berichtet melanie hug es ist die atemnot
an der ronny bauer scoop.it patientinnen
und patienten besonders leiden viele
haben vorerkrankungen und brauchen
intensive betreuung die station ist
eigentlich gynäkologie und der pfleger
eigentlich auf der wirbelsäulen station
jetzt ist es die kogit einheit eine von
fünf die pflegeteams schieben
zusatzschichten die angst schwingt immer
mit ich war ja sehr positiv und warfen
den quarantäne und auch krank also aroma
ist vor zimmer weiß ja nicht was ich
noch mal einstecken noch versucht durch
die älteren kollegen so gut wie möglich
zu schützen geben dann als risikogruppe
gehören und versucht die haltefrist von
diesen eine die station auch wegzuhalten
auch die leighton der hygiene schwester
hat alle hände voll zu tun
ihr team schult die belegschaft besorgt
hygiene-artikel testet das personal und
es dabei manchmal auch seelsorger
wir sind im prinzip diejenigen die die
befunde dann auch abends quasi von zu
hause aus dann den mitarbeitern bekannt
geben ob sie positiv sind und da spielt
man schon ein bisschen seelsorge weil
die ganz einfach angst haben die angst
wenn ein anruf kommt mitarbeiter ist
positiv
ich bin jetzt alleine im dienst derzeit
sind 70 pflegekräfte corona positiv ein
drittel in quarantäne oder zuhause bei
der kinderbetreuung sogar
physiotherapeuten springen deshalb ein
und kümmern sich um die 85 corona fälle
um personal zu sparen wurden geplante op
es vor wochen abgesagt und sieben
stationen geschlossen haben in dieser
situation wo wir mit den gesunden unsere
dienstplänen noch sichern können erst
mal gesagt wir versuchen die kranken
rauszulassen
wie lange sich diese situation
aufrechterhalten lassen wird das weiß
ich nicht
trotz der angespannten lage hier in
saalfeld ist sie in thüringen insgesamt
noch stabil
deshalb plant das bundesland ab montag
auch patienten aus sachsen aufzunehmen
die hoffnung ist ja groß dass die
impfstoffe die pandemie ausbremsen auch
in den usa dort ist bereits das zweite
präparat zugelassen worden
ab montag soll nun auch der impfstoff
des us-konzerns moderner eingesetzt
werden
die arzneimittelbehörde erteilte eine
notfall zulassung wie schon zuvor für
das serum von pfizer und biontech und
auch bei uns gibt es eine neue lage denn
die bundesregierung hat sich viele
millionen mehr impfdosen von bayern tag
und häuser gesichert als zunächst
geplant
fangen wir theo koll in berlin wie ist
dieser schritt zu bewerten na ja
interessanterweise erleben wir damit
gerade ein klares nationales signal
bisher hat deutschland ja sehr darauf
geachtet sich in eine europäische
verteilung einzureihen also nicht mehr
impfdosen zu bekommen als uns vom
bevölkerungsanteil zusteht und das
ungeachtet der umstände des dem stoff
hier erfunden wurde oder man sich mehr
leisten könnte als manch andere
nachdem aber viele länder über not
zulassung schon früher und massiver
angefangen haben zu impfen hat berlin
offensichtlich erstens druck auf die eu
ausgeübt schneller zuzulassen
das jedenfalls hat uns der vorsitzende
der arzneimittelkommission bestätigt und
jetzt sichert sich deutschland
zusätzlich 30 millionen impfdosen für
die einen ein egoistischer politischer
schritt für die anderen sicherer
erleichterungen dass jeder der
will im kommenden jahr auch geimpft
werden kann interessante hintergründe
vielen dank dafür theo nach berlin den
pfizer biontech impfstoff hat heute auch
die schweiz zugelassen
das land ist in europa derzeit mit am
stärksten von der pandemie betroffen
die ansteckungszahlen waren zwar nach
dem höchststand anfang november gefallen
doch in den letzten beiden wochen
stiegen sie wieder an
zuletzt lag der sieben tage wert pro
100000 einwohner bei 348 bei uns zum
vergleich bei 190 nach viel kritik hat
die regierung in bern die beschränkungen
jetzt verschärft einiges aber den
einzelnen kantonen überlassen
ulrike nitzschke von kanton zu kanton
verschieden heißt es in der schweiz wenn
es um verordnungen geht selbst in corona
zeiten ski freundin in einigen kantonen
erlaubt den anderen nicht der
flickenteppich im land mit einer der
höchsten infektionsraten europas soll
endlich vom tisch
unser land ist stark wenn sich alle
einbringen und unser land ist stark wenn
wir gemeinsam handeln
es braucht jetzt die ganze schweiz ein
pathetischer appell der bislang eher
zurückhaltenden schweizer regierung sie
startet ab kommenden dienstag einen
landesweiten shutdown anders sein die in
die höhe schnellenden fallzahlen nicht
in den griff zu bekommen wir sind heute
in der inzidenz 14 tage dreimal höher
als spanien fast dreimal höheres
frankreich als belgien wo wirkliches
bekannt ist dass es waren auch
schwierige situationen wird viel zu hoch
in der schweiz werden vor weihnachten
nicht nur die restaurants geschlossen
auch freizeit einrichtungen wie kinos
und museen einzelhandelsgeschäfte
bleiben offen wenn auch unter strengen
hygiene auflagen die skigebiete
überlässt der bundesrat in der
verantwortung der kantone bern und
schwyz beispielsweise haben bereits die
schließung angekündigt um die kapazität
der krankenhäuser durch wintersport
unfälle nicht zusätzlich zu belasten
haben wir uns entschieden die skigebiete
zu schließen
andere kantone wie graubünden lassen
sich diese entscheidung bis montag offen
und restaurants müssen auch nur dann
schließen wenn der reproduktions wert
ihres kantons über 1 liegt der schatten
leid kommt der flickenteppich bleibt
deutlich härter greift italien im kampf
gegen das corona virus wieder durch von
weihnachten bis zum 6 januar bleiben die
meisten geschäfte sowie bars und
restaurants geschlossen
das haus darf man dann nur aus gutem
grund verlassen
an ein paar tagen wird es allerdings
lockerungen geben
besonders hart trifft die italiener das
rund um weihnachten und neujahr reisen
zwischen den regionen verboten sind auch
österreich zieht die zügel noch mal
deutlich an
anders als italien allerdings erst nach
weihnachten damit reisende das virus
nicht ins land tragen gelten aber schon
ab heute strengere regeln bei der
einreise die sorgen für teils kilometer
lange staus an der grenze wie aktuell
auf der autobahn a3 bei passau richtung
österreich betroffen ist vor allem der
grenzübergang suben über 15 kilometer
reiht sich hier wagen an waren seit dem
morgen für die österreichische
grenzpolizei dort kontrollen durch und
direkt vor ort an der a3 steht jetzt
meine kollegin patricia schäfer patricia
abbas kontrolliert in die polizei genau
worum geht es ihr
petra die österreichischen grenze wollen
wissen wohin jemand unterwegs ist aber
nur durch reist oder einreist in dem
fall müsste man sich nämlich zehn tage
in quarantäne begeben das besagt die
neue einreise verordnung die in
österreich seit heute gilt also ganz
konkret schauen die grenzer ins auto
hinein fragen wohin die leute unterwegs
sind und haben uns gesagt naja wenn
einer in einem bulgarischen auto nach
bulgarien unterwegs ist dann glaubt man
dass ihm halt wir sehen allerdings auch
viele nordeuropäische kennzeichen viele
osteuropäische aus rumänien aus
slowenien
vom balkan überhaupt und die deshalb
gehen polizei und behörden davon aus
dass es sich hier um einen heimreise
verkehr über die feiertage handelt
menschen mit osteuropäischen wurzeln die
heime zu ihren familien fahren über die
feiertage also zu einer verminderung der
reisetätigkeit hat hier haben die lok
downs die verschärfungen jedenfalls
nicht geführt fünf kilometer von der
grenze entfernt steht der verkehr seit
heute nacht und wahrscheinlich auch noch
ein bisschen weiter
vielen dank für diese information
patricia schäfer war das von der a3 die
korona krise ist teuer
die neuverschuldung des bundes im
nächsten jahr liegt bei knapp 180
milliarden euro für aktuelle hilfen sind
monatlich 15 milliarden eingeplant
die botschaft des finanzministers heute
wir tun was nötig ist so lange es nötig
ist sagte er der funke mediengruppe
frank buchwald über corona und die
finanzen berlin am letzten samstag vor
weihnachten die geschäfte zu bars und
kneipen sowie so viele unternehmen von
corona hart getroffen sie hoffen auf
hilfe und alle fragen sich wie lange
noch der finanzminister aber beruhigt
olaf scholz im zeitungsinterview
finanziell können wir den lockdown lange
durchhalten weil wir über eine robuste
volkswirtschaft mit sehr
leistungsfähigen und international
wettbewerbsfähigen unternehmen verfügen
wir tun was nötig ist so lange es nötig
ist
abschlagszahlungen für dezember sollen
in den nächsten tagen kommen so das
wirtschaftsministerium
anfang januar dann geld aus der
überbrückungshilfe drei höchste zeit
sagt die union die in betrieben fehlen
jetzt die eine und deshalb brauchen sie
jetzt unterstützt er sie brauchen jetzt
liquidität das gilt für die
überbrückungshilfe das gilt aber auch
für die zahlungen selbst der muss tempo
gemacht werden die linke aber beklagt
dass reiche nicht
ich habe ehrlich gesagt kein verständnis
dafür dass die beschäftigten in der
gastronomie die jetzt auf trinkgeld
verzichten müssen die ohnehin wenig
verdienen mit 60 prozent
kurzarbeitergeld über die runden kommen
müssen ebenso im handel
dauerhaft könnte der staat jedoch nicht
für die wirtschaft ein stehen
die fdp und empfiehlt konzepte für eine
zeit nach der krise
es muss jetzt alles getan werden was
wachstum generiert und am besten fängt
man jetzt schon damit an die zeit die
jetzt nach der pandemie auf uns zukommt
muss eine zeit des kräftigen
wirtschaftswachstums werden
das aber dürfte noch eine weile dauern
und bis dahin bleibt vor allem hoffnung
auf vorweihnachtliche ruhe und die
vernunft der menschen die zeit läuft ab
beim braig city in zwölf tagen scheidet
großbritannien aus dem eu binnenmarkt
und der zollunion aus brüssel und london
verhandeln immer noch über ein abkommen
scheitern die gespräche würden unter
anderem zölle erhoben mit gravierenden
folgen für die wirtschaft aus london
berichtet yasin her ein wenn sich eines
gut im ausland verkaufen lässt dann ist
das luxus mit dem gewissen britischen
etwas hier in den produktionshallen im
crew wo einst die motoren der spitfire
flugzeuge vom band liefen
haben sie sich beim autohersteller
bentley auf den endgültigen eu-austritt
ohne deal so gut wie es geht vorbereitet
aber reicht das
das ist wie wir nur von einer klippe
springst ohne den fallschirm vorher
getestet zu haben wir haben alle zoll
auflagen angepasst unsere lieferanten
benachrichtigt und platz für extra
vorräte eingerichtet aber wir mussten so
etwas noch nie tun wenn es alle machen
flüssiger warenverkehr ist für die
britische industrie überlebenswichtig
genauso wie den import von lebensmitteln
aufrecht zu erhalten
seit tagen kommt es rund um die
kanalhafen immer wieder zu kilometer
lang lkw staus da immer noch unklarheit
über einen deal herrscht wird schnell
noch rein und raus geschafft was geht
und von optimismus auf den letzten
metern ist auch der regierungschef weit
entfernt unsere tür ist offen wir werden
weiter verhandeln aber ich muss sagen
das ist schwierig bleibt für die briten
ist der dreck sind jetzt gerade schlicht
eine sorge zu viel
corona ist viel wichtiger rexit ist in
den hintergrund getreten
wir müssen erst corona loswerden dann
können wir wieder an die politik denken
wie zur bestätigung wurde heute
beschlossen dass aufgrund einer sich
offensichtlich schneller verbreitenden
variante des kit 19 virus london und der
südosten wieder in eines shutdown müssen
und für weihnachten landesweit größere
beschränkungen herrschen kommt es zu
einem no deal bei exit wird es auch zu
neuer nicht besonders fröhlich zugehen
die bundesregierung hat nach
medienberichten an diesem wochenende
mehrere gefangene deutsche mitglieder
des sogenannten islamischen staates
zurück nach deutschland geholt
es soll sich um drei frauen mit ihren
kindern sowie mehrere waisenkinder
handeln
sie waren bisher in lagern in nordsyrien
interniert rund drei monate nachdem das
flüchtlingslager moria abgebrannt ist
hat entwicklungshilfeminister müller csu
die weiter katastrophalen bedingungen
für migranten auf der griechischen insel
lesbos angeprangert das neue lager car
at t sei leider nicht besser
die hilfsorganisation ärzte ohne grenzen
müsse jetzt babys gegen wundstarrkrampf
impfen weil sie in massen zelten von
ratten gebissen worden sein
müller spricht von entsetzlichen
zuständen mitten in europa vier jahre
sind seit dem anschlag auf dem berliner
weihnachtsmarkt am breitscheidplatz
vergangen
ein gedenkgottesdienst in der
gedächtniskirche beginnt in diesen
minuten
punkt 20 uhr zwei dem zeitpunkt des
anschlags sollen zwölf glockenschläge an
die zwölf todesopfer erinnern
am 19 dezember 2016 steuerte der
islamistische attentäter anis amri einen
lkw in die besuchermenge des
weihnachtsmarktes
neben den zwölf toten wurden mehr als 50
menschen teilweise schwer verletzt
und jetzt machen wir einen schnitt und
gehen zum sport über mit norbert könig
ja erst mal geht es um einen fußball
club der einfach nicht mehr gewinnen
kann auch kurzzeit trainer huub stevens
schafft es nicht die schwarze serie von
schalke 04 zu beenden seit mitte januar
kein sieg in der bundesliga heute
saisonniederlage nummer 9 für den
tabellenletzten aufsteiger arminia
bielefeld gewinnt in der gelsenkirchener
arena 1 zu 0 mainz hängt auch unten fest
0 zu 1 gegen bremen mönchengladbach
verliert 1 zu 2 gegen hoffenheim rb
leipzig überraschend nur 0 zu 0 gegen
den 1 fc köln augsburg gegen eintracht
frankfurt 0 zu 2 das absolute topspiel
am abend tabellenführer leverkusen gegen
bayern münchen ausführlich im aktuellen
sportstudio gestern union berlin gegen
borussia dortmund 2 zu 1 schon mit einem
unentschieden würde bayer leverkusen die
tabellenführung verteidigen leipzig
momentan zweiter vor den bayern dann
klafft schon eine lücke zu dortmund
union berlin und wolfsburg in der
unteren hälfte spielen morgen die
nachbarn freiburg und hertha
gegeneinander wichtige punktgewinne
schaffen werder köln und bielefeld mainz
und schalke schon mit deutlichem abstand
zur nichtabstiegszone zu gast im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr ist
handball nationaltorwart johannes bitter
knapp vier wochen vor der umstrittenen
weltmeisterschaft in ecke markus
eisenbichler einem platz auf dem podest
beim weltcup skispringen in engelberg
nur um einen zehntelpunkt verpasst zwei
flüge auf 133 und danach auf die
tagesbestweite von 138 meter bringen dem
weltmeister von der grossschanze platz
vier
sechster verpasste seine sieges serie
setzt halber grane redford ebenfalls 138
meter im zweiten durchgang reichen dem
norweger zum vierten erfolg nacheinander
die führung im gesamt weltcup hat er
ausgebaut vincenz geiger gewinnt in
ramsau den vierten weltcup wettkampf der
saison in der nordischen kombination
gleichzeitig der vierte sieg seiner
karriere
vinzens geiger hatte sich schon beim
springen eine gute ausgangsposition
erarbeitet platz vier mit
vergleichsweise geringem rückstand von
25 sekunden auf jan magnus rieber den
besten springer der damit als erster in
die loipe geht
die entscheidung fällt erst auf der
zielgeraden geiger und riva kopf an kopf
aber der sonst so überlegene norweger
muss schon vor der ziellinie erkennen
dass er heute den deutschen nicht
schlagen kann
geiger sorgt damit für den ersten
deutschen sieg dieser saison beim
biathlon weltcup in hochfilzen hat
franziska preuß beim letzten schießen
den möglichen podestplatz im
verfolgungsrennen aus den händen gegeben
nach insgesamt zwei fehlern landet sie
am ende auf rang sechs
den sieg holt sich die norwegerinnen
tiere lag auf denise herrmann konnte
sich nach platz 23 im sprint dank der
zweitbesten laufzeit immerhin noch auf
rang neun verbessern
bei den männern kommt benedikt doll beim
sieg des norwegers tony hawk ride als
bester deutscher auf rang 13
und das war es von samstag genau was bei
uns beendet leichter regen morgen das
sonnige wetter im norden zu den
aussichten in ganz deutschland gleich
gunther tiersch das war es von uns
vielen dank für ihr interesse
marietta slomka und das heute journal um
drei viertel 11 und wir sind morgen
wieder für sie da um 7 einen schönen
samstagabend wünschen wir ihnen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer morgen wird
es fast überall mal wieder trüb sein bei
uns in deutschland eine schwache
regenfront legt sich quer über
deutschland verbunden ist das ganze mit
diesem massiven tief tour zentrum
draußen auf dem atlantik bei island und
das wird uns in den nächsten tagen dann
vor allen dingen den nächsten woche
viele regengebiete aus westen über
deutschland hinweg lenken
ja heute nacht ist nur leichter regen
der von westen her aufziehen wird
schwacher regen vom oberrhein bis nach
schleswig holstein nach osten hin wird
es klar sein
ja in den niederungen an der donau
bleibt es neblig und es wird im osten
und süden wieder frostig 0 bis minus 4
grad sonst sind es im norden und westen
etwa fünf bis acht grad und tagsüber
haben wir eine ähnliche
temperaturverteilung also wieder kühl in
den nebelgebieten hier an der donau
sonst im norden und westen sind es sechs
bis zwölf grad und ist es vielfach trüb
in deutschland es regnet am vormittag
noch ein bisschen stärker hier von
südwesten her das ganze zieht richtung
ostsee weiter im nordwesten ist es auf
jeden fall trocken ab und zu kann die
sonne herauskommt genauso wie im osten
im süden na ja da haben wir den
niederungen natürlich die nebel der
lichtet sich kaum und dann kommt der
regen am anfang nächster woche schon am
montagnachmittag bis mittwoch regnet es
dann weiter am donnerstag heiligabend
wird es kühler und es könnte oberhalb
von 300 metern auch schneien
ich wünsche einen schönen abend und
machen sie es gut